we do have indeed a very special I guess
Gary first of all welcome back to the
show we haven't seen you since uh day
one how did you experience the first
couple of rounds here at the super
Adventures class uh there were many
draws but uh I have to say that it's
it's not because of the lack of the
fighting spirit so and
clearly you know you could see yesterday
that uh they will try uh to win the game
just you know until a very last pawn and
uh I think it was a bit shocking to see
how do they managed to lose this this
end game but you know it's just it's
quite amazing I think it's this it's
it's it's it's it's again the game is
not you know just it's doesn't make a
front page or newspaper but it's an
interesting moment because I mean he was
it was dead raw of course absolutely
dead draw uh what happened there no
that's I can tell you what's happening
that's a c played B5 you know this it's
uh uh thinking that you can force to
draw though he didn't have to do
whatever K5 I mean H5 I mean any
movement probably would be a draw in a
few yeah few moves but but the five one
take I think he missed Bishop takes me
one before and before which is very very
nice but before fix the pawn on B5 now
it's probably still you know okay okay
black is already struggling because it's
they're losing the pawn but the
typically one even sometimes two Pawns
in in opposite color Bishops and games
it's not a big deal but this was very
unusual structure because black had too
many weaknesses yeah as many typically
yeah it's F7
G6 potentially if you start moving pawns
there so normally you know they say oh
you have to put your your pawns on the
on uh on the opposite colors of your
Bishop
but uh
that's actually worked very much in in
in uh rapport's favor yeah because in
the white phones you know um trap black
bishop and uh it's limited these
movements why black bones you know were
excellent targets
I won't be surprised I don't know I have
not know this game but G5 wasn't
decisive mistake it was I think it's
just instinctively because you know it's
you have many weaknesses and you have to
start thinking which again is still it's
tough because you know losing B5 form
and then C Pawn will be moving and then
all these pawns will be weak I think
it's probably I would probably play H5
H4 just you know exchanging the pawns
but limiting number of the pawns G5
I could and again brilliant F4 he fixed
the nut which is interesting before fix
one with this and then
you know why I play G5 because it's so
natural because after B4 you know he
could have expected F4 and now the
moment I saw it I just we discussed it
here and said look with too many
weaknesses
think you know it's it's it's it's lost
again I haven't followed the game in
details but very very instructive end
here very instructive there's so many
story lines and specifically today of
course everybody's eyes were on that
game nepo versus yes yes things what did
you expect before the game no I expected
it would be a big fight and and of
course you know nepo playing white so it
would give him a chance to take some
sort of the psychological or the moral
revenge for for fostana and uh and he
has been trying he has been trying so he
played D4 it's the it seems surprise for
us so
um but it just shows that you know he
had plenty of ideas there for the match
well prepared and and I think it's a
very interesting game this is again the
many chess fans they sing Oh Queen's
gone not a big deal but we're now from
Berlin that is just you know
disappearance of Queens doesn't mean
that the game is dull it could be very
interesting very entertaining of course
we had one Berlin today
yeah but
um also this it's a very interesting
position I remember first time I
analyzed it in depths before match was
Nigel because Nigel played this this uh
this uh classical uh
Queen's Gambit with Bishop yes but yes
yeah he hasn't played in the match but
we analyzed it before the match was
Queen and free this end game though I
have to say that you know I I was I was
planning to play H4 not the Knight of H4
which again it's another move it's this
uh it seems that the the lately the move
has been not refused uh not not refuted
but uh black neutralized and I'm not
afraid it's I think it's chronic's idea
yes it's just this oh yes Carlson I
think Carlson Carson exactly yes it's
Carlson so there's this with Knight on
H4 and then pushing and it was very
interesting in it it's whether it was
prepared by ding or not but I I was
quite you know intrigued by the position
after Bishop C2 because that was a plan
so this is and the F4 now he wants he
wants to push the the pawn and and uh
and black okay black black has to bring
Knight on night night on night on D6 but
it's just it's it's a long way so and
Bishop C2 and uh and that was
interesting one do you think he missed
this move Knight to B1 because according
to the engine at least at this point
white was borderline winning look it
seems to me that white has a huge
Advantage now because of this is the you
know F5 is is is is is a problem the
square of five and uh and uh just you
know removing bishop and basically
keeping this Knight you know total
controller five square I mean paralyzes
black position because this bishop has
it's very hard to move because night
night will be cutting the bishop so um
the whole idea of you know of playing
f54 what did he prepared it I don't know
just it's
A5 was the first time where he spent
quite a lot of time to it yeah that's
that's that's probably you know probably
D4 was a surprise to him uh uh he came
up with this you know with this plan D5
and seems to me that was his plan for
the match to play solid games I think
net point now after he played Knight B1
he said ah I could have played it in the
last rapid game I bet you that came
through his mind I could have put in the
last rapid game and that this is the
position I could have yeah that's this
in the last moment so
um
um and after everyone I thought it's
really difficult for black and and I
immediately saw the C5 he had to play C5
at one point so and and again I don't
know what this is Rook A5 which is the
interesting idea because the uh I think
the idea was that after 95 no no here
for 95 Knight B6 Knight D2 and now
Bishop C4 I think that's that's that's I
guess that was that was yeah because
night night is hanging and yeah and then
it's just you know and then you go B5
and it's maybe still maybe an unpleasant
but the kid pawns are stronger yes
exactly yes so yes yes before yes there
would be five and that's usually take
King D7 and they just you bring it up
back and yeah it's maybe it's I don't
know still still looks looks doesn't
look good to me so this it looks like a
center but you have something to play
for maybe yes that's the I just again I
I don't think that's it's it's Bishop E2
and he played with C5 here he played the
season Yes actually I think maybe here
white could even played King of two you
know just I don't just because I'm not
sure let's see before just it makes much
sense it's just okay
but in general so and if when Knight B6
I don't know what's the what about
what's what's Black's next move now
maybe if even if I play something with
Knight C3 I don't know I'm not sure
because
C4 Square
you don't really want the place no but
that's but that's that's exactly what
because people are not be not D2 and
then and then and then so this is yeah
and and Nepal wanted to to force it
again I just don't know that's those my
thoughts and and then ding you know I
think he found the only move 98 and B5
again it still may not be enough to save
the game but that was the only chance
otherwise black would lose just you know
the total paralysis yeah this white will
start improving the position at the 5G 4
H and then eventually E4 will win the
game yeah after so um he uh here so in
the game it was yes
but now finally you have big exactly
that's all because the key is after
Bishop are free so B5 if he is simply B5
and you can take on D5 yes yeah the take
that before and Knight is hanging yeah
that's nice yes yes that's nice yes
that's that's an idea that's the one
otherwise you know he could have
parallel and Bishop on the faith you
cannot you cannot win the win they win
The Rook there so that's that's their
Bishop yeah he still wants to
yeah and if you take there this bishop
before was checked so so uh I think
that's the that was the only chance and
being founded and and then uh I think
NEPA also recognized that he should yeah
should stop I don't understand E4 you
understand there was nowhere he had to
play before now yes seems like B4 was
the best yeah because this otherwise
again I'll just wait to have decided
look at this Bishops yeah so before
take take Knight takes Knight takes and
here is here's a surprise like fairly
quickly
yeah why not G4 that's a very good
question yeah this is Steve why don't
you four you're right C4 yeah but you
have a knight on F5 I mean this is
totally paralyzed position and I don't
know what what I can do
there's something about his conversion
nepo's conversion in the match under
five you know this is it just it's it's
totally held this position blacks that
holds the black position under Reno uh
almost paralysis yeah and I next take
next movements before yeah I'm I don't
know Bishop D2 still bishopsy four years
yeah
that's there yeah I think so you get
this position Bishop takes D5 root takes
C1 I mean this is such a yeah
foreign
why not G4 yeah yeah very odd very odd
so this is the and this is something
that Richard report also mentioned when
he came here
um following the match and being so
close to ding he noticed that Neville
has huge problems converting converting
his advantages and this is exactly what
we're seeing uh so what's what's
happened on this is he going to the same
game yesterday yeah um so after Castle
take take Rook do you want Rook to d8
King to D3 and F5 Rook to B4 trying to
at some point take an H5 this is the
position
horror his chance is looking to convert
this one
so you should believe something like
Rook E2 King c yeah but what H4 H3
that's that's already he's pushing yes
H3 now is
or maybe he wants to start with Rook G4
and then
yeah because by this but the king C3
Rook D2 and take the pawn yeah that's
that's the that's the that's the plan
yeah and maybe black should play Rogue
but once you get to that point do I have
some ideas so for example let's say I go
here you go here already Rook to E4
first I was booking C3
because
yeah and now maybe Rook to E4
we try to find some counter play like
this
yeah
so I'm still a fight no no no no no
Rooks end game always a fight yeah yeah
that's all the fight so that's it yeah
especially against very few pawns left
um and black could create some counter
play so yeah yeah I mean
um
I would say that like never had such a
good position
yeah yeah we're in the middle of uh
round three who's making which player is
making an impression on
you look this is it's a very very even
field very even field and uh I think
it's rarely we have tournaments where
Neil every player you know could
could so many decisive games but it's
not because of the lack of fighting
Spirit but more because they they
they're all good so that's the by I
think that's that's the main reason and
uh and I you know I think it's it's very
very entertaining tournament so I I
don't know what's happening with mvl
today I mean he collapsed yeah very
quickly so it seems that you know that
H4 move three you know
has has
yeah but he I mean he lost so many kids
it's just you know again it's to me it's
quite an odd you know move because I
played Kings Indian and that's that's
Kings
look they believe that King Sydney is a
bad opening so that's why you can even
play with H4 so
um but um and you can roll the Gambit
from my Optics you know he had a very
good position I don't know that's this
day but and then I just said as I looked
elsewhere and it came back just look at
the screen maybe so it's gone
game was over yes game is over here so
um uh but again all games are
interesting so that's this is Simon
again traditional Berlin still you know
it's amazing they played Berlin
every tournament you know just the
little bits you know right and left you
know just improvements but it's still
interesting fight
okay this this game probably is it's
it's a Droid
not the big deal we've had some chances
but but he had he but he had some in in
in in the opening I mean it was the was
it what's the real good chance for white
I mean
um it felt like I don't know this is
Rook D1 yes
yes
tactically it works because Bishop G5
you have F6 ideas
um but of course to G8 is not the only
move you can go king of fa yeah C4 yeah
you don't want to touch that yeah
yes that's true that's true yes
this lady is just pushing this yeah it
looked a bit dangerous to me though
that's again that's the way I they can
I'm not pretending to be a big expert in
Berlin but this is you have other
players you know who knows much but but
still again Optics yeah yeah I thought
maybe it's been difficult but it's this
but
yeah that's the idea just
uh and what about E6 I mean I know it's
primitive about this what about E6 years
before yeah here he is Ecco yeah yeah
and after X is
75 and for whatever reason the engine is
saying that the two Bishops are just
strong very very strong
you cannot get C4 going because B3 all
the time
can we
okay it's okay from G5 yes
engine ideas
I'm still struggling to to
so I still play C3 so I'm just you know
I'm
57 yes
yeah it's just a G7 Pawn is Untouchables
yeah I'm still you know
why I want an impression that you feel
like white has a grip on the position
you know just again maybe it's
to leave up there free now
yeah
see okay so Rook H5 you actually want to
take that pawn mostly I'm not sure
let's let's try it out
31 let's say I I cannot go there because
see take take
so let's defend this guy
Bishop have six next yeah next
next yeah D5 was pretty strong here so I
have to say I'm
yeah
B3 and c4u C5 that's the problem five
and then there we see foreign
yeah that's um
bring some
sad memories to me if you're 2000 but
let's give credit to crumbling so we
came up with the one of the most
stunning discoveries of 21st century
that was already done uh bringing
bringing the still probably much popular
yes yes yeah that's again just
recognizing the the potential of this
opening Gary thank you very much always
great I think there is one
do the versus who you mentioned is
struggling this one against Bogdan
Daniel Dak
and they're actually getting in time
travel right now they're only 33 seconds
this is one of his biggest issues he
always gets in time
it's it's very unpleasant yeah yeah I
don't think
is okay do the let's assume do they will
play this end game better than he would
yesterday yeah so what's the how many
moves left
there's still 11 12 moves 23 seconds 25
and Counting yes okay against five
minutes and 30 seconds for that that's
it
but what
I guess
I mean he has to take the Knight the
Knight on B6 is not doing anything
played with seven seconds Knight takes
C8
we're expecting bad things before which
he does
still equal parts but no it's a solar
pawns it's about it's white totally
dominates if a free can give two Knight
D4 Rook C2 this this I think I would say
people play A5 probably now
so you would give big chances to do that
to converters I won't even play five
fingers at least try to do something yes
maybe I don't know but just at least
maybe Knight goes on D6 and yeah
okay
no no no no no 94.
what you did is 94. yeah that's okay
for black can play 94.
oh um no no this is this so it's white
to move right now Knight 26 I was just
playing yeah so now this one didn't take
them on B7 I take yes they could not be
so nice it's really yeah
but um
same game but it's very important
very very unpleasant so Services almost
always indefensible yes
again it's uh yeah if you make time
control still you know that's uh even
without rules you know the NBA might be
very unpleasant but can a limited number
of Pawns yeah let's see here let's see
if Dura you know managers I think it
gets a bit nervous now so is that stuff
he is yesterday yeah Miracles handling
yeah right like how do you
recovery but that's you know that's what
happens with people often they don't
understand is that it's you know it's he
was he totally relaxed the game was over
I mean he just stopped thinking yeah it
was just more like I played B5 and then
you have to start it's very difficult
because he already switched off I think
his his senses yeah and then after
before he realized that ah I I have to
think and it's immediately you know this
is his first challenge you know he just
made immediately inside the Panic at
that point it's it's not so much Panic
it's just you know it's very difficult
to come back because you know this is
you started the game and you're
preparing you know you're just you're
mentally you're ready and then again
playing games over so give me probably
thinking about next tomorrow
yeah and all of a sudden
he takes the uh report uh took on D1 was
a bishop played before
just the first test
yeah
Gary okay as usual always great inside
thank you very much we'll see you around
yes thank you thank you Christian thank
you Gary yeah